So here's the answer. The first one is true. S
index 3 is exactly the same thing as S index
1 plus 1 plus 1 because 1 plus 1, plus
1 evaluates to 3. These two have the same value.
If S is a string with at least 4 characters
in it, this will get the fourth character from S.
If s has fewer than 4 characters, both of these
will produce an error. The second choice, both of these actually
also have the same value. S index 0 will get
us the first character of S as long as S
has at least one character; otherwise it will produce an
error. S plus Swill produce the string, concatenating S with itself
but its first character is still the same as the
first character of S, so these two are equivalent. The third
option is not equivalent. So here we're taking the first
character of S, concatenating that with the second character of S.
Here we're taking from S, the 0 plus 1th
character, which is, evaluates to 1 so that's the
second character of S. This is just going to be
one character, this is two characters. They're never equivalent. The
fourth option is sometimes equivalent. If S is a
string with at least two characters then S index
1 is the second character from S. S plus
ity index 1 is the second character for S. The
problem is that if S has less than two characters. So suppose our value of S was
just a one letter string. S index 1 will
be an error. There is no second character from
S. S plus ity index 1 would be the
second character of the string that resolves from that
concatenation which would actually be the I. So these
are not always equivalent. They are equivalent in the
case where S has at least two characters.
The final option, we have S negative 1,
so that means the last character of S. And we have S plus S, which produces
the string which concatenates S with itself in
X negative 1. That's going to be the last
character of concatenating S with itself, which is
the same as the last character of S.